e
good morning and welcome to the special
committee on uh the division for
Children and Youth Youth and families um
I'm the chairman representative Lon and
we have a good number of our members
here today although some were unable to
make it um to start off we will be
having a work session where it's just
the committee and normally this is for
an hour um should we and generally when
we hear from the public is later on at
the regular meeting which is noticed at
11 o'clock this is for the committee and
then we have the time to hear from the
public afterwards um as as this moves
forward we'll figure out um we we'll
we'll figure out all of our processes
more but a lot of it too we want to make
sure that people are taking the
appropriate amount of time when they do
speak later on and make sure that when
people are speaking they're speaking to
policies not people we don't want to
hear any names because we're talking
about the overall issues and we're not
talking about any particular individuals
um that's to be dealt with in in other
ways um so with this we're going to be
digging into due process um this is one
of those areas where everybody has a
there there's many different
interpretations and we actually have
some from the Constitution Center to be
able to take a look at and see some of
the different ways that due process has
been viewed this is a description of due
process from the ACLU of Pennsylvania um
I Look to bring some of those uh centerr
groups in order to look and see what is
going on as far as the information I
have in front of me I'm not sure that
we'll actually look at all of this today
but there was actually a pretty pretty
thorough work by prop publica looking
about um due process and looking to some
issues that have happened around the
country regarding um children and
families so there's some very
interesting discussions and it might
actually be a little easier to look at
some of these issues and see how other
states have succeeded or perhaps not
done as well as they could have because
there's a lot of these common threads
and common issues from state to state
and just by removing the people from the
policies it might be a little bit easier
to talk about how this state or that
state did things well or not so well as
opposed to uh getting as close to home
early on as we're looking through all of
these different particular issues um so
what I just handed out from the ACLU
Pennsylvania says the due process is
what separates a free Society from a
police state when the 14th Amendment of
the Constitution says the government
shall not deprive any person of life
liberty or property without due process
of law that does not mean that the
government cannot take away a person's
life liberty or property but that it
cannot take those things away without
first giving that person a fair chance
to defend him or herself for instance
the government cannot imprison someone
or take away his or her children without
allowing the person to challenge the
government's action um to me that seems
like a pretty good intro introduction to
it is there anybody who takes issue with
any of that
characterization okay wonderful so we
have some ground rules I like I I like
agreement I absolutely like agreement um
so now this is from the national
Constitution Center this is a common
process and obviously we're not going to
be able to read through all of these
materials but I wanted to highlight some
of the issues that are here so within
this at the national Constitution Center
they did quite a bit looking at the 14th
amendment in the due process clause um
because the due process clause of the
14th Amendment Echoes that of the Fifth
Amendment um and this is with the
interpretation um that the Fifth
Amendment is only against the federal
government um I'm not a constitutional
scholar um but as we look to this um
this has a lot of ways where the 14th
Amendment ensures that those same
protections of rights are done by the
states as well as by the federal
government um so the 14th Amendment
prohibits States from depriving any
person of life liberty or property
without due process of law
and at the time so I'm going to just
read a little bit from this because some
of it does dovetail with some of what
we've been discussing when it was
adopted the Clause was understood to
mean that the government could deprive a
person's rights only according to the
law applied by a court yet since then
the Supreme Court is elaborated
significantly on this core understanding
as the examples above suggest um which I
didn't read these rights protected under
the 14th amendment can be understood in
three categories the first is procedural
due process the second is is the
individual rights listed in the Bill of
Rights Incorporated against the states
process so um getting into the
procedural due process that's the
procedures that the government needs to
do and this this um is saying that
historically that entailed a jury trial
um however there has been some um over
the past two centuries states have
developed a variety of Institutions and
procedures for adjudicating disputes so
the minimum of that is notice an
opportunity to be heard and an impartial
tribunal um so I think that those are
three things that we need to make sure
that we key in on the notice the
opportunity to be heard and an impartial
tribunal um so as we're looking at
everything procedurally we want to make
sure that there is that not notice
there's that opportunity and the
impartiality so that's something that
may be a theme that comes back um from
time so when we're looking at the
expansion of those property rights um
that's that's not one that we really
need to look at here because um a lot of
these do say there seems to be some good
consensus among on I what I reviewed
that your family and making sure that
you're protecting your family is one of
those interests obviously there's that
interest as well of the child that are
balanced see so does anybody have any
thoughts that they want to share at this
point representative
Weber um thank you thank you for the the
overview and the materials um and I will
just say that the analysis and I'm
certainly not a constitutional scholar
and I um but the analysis as was
presented to us at law school is very
similar you look first is is there a
protected interest and I cannot think
that anybody would not agree that the
right to raise your family is a prote
interest and that's exactly what you
were talking about about the inclusion
of Rights um and and
secondly if there is a protected
interest then the question is what
processes do and that goes exactly to
the notice the opportunity to be heard
in an impartial tribunal um and in in if
you are looking strictly speaking at
DCF
procedures the
procedures already in incorporate all of
those
things how they play out in individual
cases may may be an issue um but uh and
I can think of all kinds of
um examples for examples when when the
courts all closed down because of covid
uh there was less opportunity either to
be hurt or for an impartial um that's
that's an extreme example so those those
may be things that are looked at as as
we go through but um how each of these
individual requirements plays out is is
an important inquiry so thank you uh
thank you for that I I would agree that
how they play out and not just on paper
but in practice is absolutely critical
um I I believe I referenced that
propublica has done a large
investigation into this and there's
actually been some legislative work in
both Texas and New York regarding
Miranda style work warnings in child
welfare welfare cases um this suggests
that the idea of notification of Rights
and actually having a recognition that
that notification of Rights has happened
and the person understands it is an
issue that is of significance not just
in New Hampshire but across the country
um so in um last September um Child
Protective Services in Texas are now
required to read parents or
constitutional rights similar to the
Miranda Rights uh because this was a law
enacted by the state legislature because
there had been some um there were quite
a few cases that were brought before
where people were not notified of their
rights specifically they need to be
notified that they have a right to
remain silent to have a lawyer present
and to decline searches of their home or
their children without a court order um
this is actually one of the areas where
there had been um a lot of disparities
about how this was done this was
something where lower income or um
people that are black Hispanic and lower
income were having significant problems
with this um in Texas so they put this
law into place um so this this was
actually a similar law was in New York
state and that one was blocked in the
legislature so it's interesting that the
process and the way that things go
differ differs from state to state but
despite uh similar challenges in New
York um they actually did not pass that
so this this might be an interesting um
interesting bills to look at and see
what these other states have done and
order to see where our Stacks up if
we're already more protective or if we
can have some other improvements because
um I I I don't know if all of you are
having people speak to you about this
but I've had a few people that did not
feel that they were informed of their
rights obviously we can have that
testimony come in um but we do want to
make sure that especially as people are
entering this they understand their
we don't I don't think we need to get
point
okay um and so looking forward as well
one of the things that'll be important
is to find out not just from testimony
but from actual complaints that have
been filed to understand what's
happening um this is one where I'm
putting request out to the office of the
child advocate to get the records that
they have on complaints that are related
to Due Process um and then also to check
if there's any other places that are
receiving these complaints because we
would like to compile those have them
come in and explain any trends that they
are seeing um so that we can look and
make sure that this is something that is
sorry I'm trying to find this there was
uh one that was
um really highlighting how important due
process is not just for the families
that are separated but quite a few of
the children who were not removed from
their homes when they should have been
um that was an issue of due process as
well because evidence wasn't followed up
um there was um conflicting evidence and
that's led to poor outcomes on both
sides so this is one of those areas
where we need to recognize that this is
going to protect children and families
all using the same tools and uh that's
kind of a nice place to be in because if
we can use the same same metrics in
order to protect everybody involved
that's absolutely key um I guess I
wanted to see if anybody had any
thoughts because I feel like I've been a
wall of words representative long thank
you uh Madam chair uh the last statement
you made it's also uh cases are
unfounded if you don't allow them to go
in your house and do an interview with
either a child or yourself so they're
unfounded so we wouldn't be able to
figure out uh whether it was fault on
the agency or or it was unfounded
because you weren't allowed to uh so so
that's that's a
double a double bite you know okay so
then to follow up on that so if it is
unfounded because they're not able to go
into the home is that because there
wasn't enough in evidence um in order to
get a warrant to then go into the home
after it was refused
uh could be or could not be they don't
you don't you don't have to allow them
to interview you or the
child uh but with a warrant they would
correct
uh okay sorry okay representative Greg
so um thank you madam chairman
chairwoman so in order to get a warrant
you would need when you have a a
suspicion you need more evidence so in
order to get more evidence in cases of
family mistreatment you're actually
going to need to have interviews with
the child or the parent if they're
saying no then that's where it stops the
ability to get a warrant is going to
take something more serious like um I
mean there have been broken bones where
they still said that they couldn't
didn't have enough to get a warrant
because the parent gives an excuse maybe
in the hospitals to why it happened but
they don't have enough evidence without
being able to get in the house so this
is where we're lacking due process for
the children um because you just can't
do it representative
Weber and and my question is actually
for those who are active members of the
children and family law committee is I'm
trying to remember about the warrant
issue um is is it DCF that gets the
warrant or are the warrants warrants are
part of a criminal action DCF doesn't do
warrants and to answer one of the issues
that you just passed out parents now
have the right and correct me if I'm
wrong because I'm I'm pulling from
various brain cells some of which may
not be working well um if a parent meets
you at the door and says you can't come
in you can't come in if a parent meets
you and says I'm not going to let you
interview my child you have to find
another way and that is easier if the
child is in school you may be able to do
it through school but I'm not sure of my
own knowledge where the line is if the
parent says and you're never going to
talk to my kid every anywhere uh because
the cases that I know about have
involved teens at school rather than
small children right under so I'd love
to hear from folks about what the actual
current standard of of things in DCF is
about
that representative
thank you madam chair um so with respect
to schools uh most schools
will ask the advice of the parent youf
will show up I want to talk with Johnny
Smith uh hang on a minute I'm going to
call their parents make sure it's okay
or some of them will just let them in so
if they just let them in and they talk
to the child they talk to the child uh
but historically it's asking the parents
and if the parent says go to the house
first and the parent says I don't want
you talking to my child they can't go to
the school
representative thank you shamman
Lan isn't the police department have the
right to go in and do a warrant search
and
interview um thank you if the if they
have enough evidence in order to have a
judge give a warrant then yes um but
unless they're in Pursuit I believe
there's Pursuit for an imminent risk
that sort of thing but otherwise they
need a warrant in order to go in thank
you you're welcome representative Greg
thank you madam chairman I think this is
probably one of those areas to get super
specific it'd be helpful to hear from
DCF but from the cases that I've known
of um firsthand or experienced or seen
the paperwork for what generally happens
is is you have a suspect of a situation
where a child's being uh maltreated you
have a DCF investigation let's say
they're able to talk to the children
they're able to talk to the parents then
dcyf takes a look at it and with their
you know vast knowledge figure out okay
is this something that we just maybe
talk to the parents like hey this isn't
the best form of parenting you know you
kind of give them a warning like this is
not this is not good because
XYZ um there are other cases where it
takes it to a criminal crial level uh
where there is a criminal statute then
dcyf will involve the police department
but you don't have the police generally
jumping in with warrants unless maybe
there's a
fatality uh something or a missing child
something like that even then it can
take a little bit longer uh there's
Extreme Caution when they talk about
removing children from Families First of
all it's expensive there's not a lot of
resources so we're limited on that but
they're very very careful so there are a
lot lot of times where things have been
unfounded that shouldn't have there's
been broken bones we've heard testimony
of babies that the explanations given is
just not there but the parents won't let
them investigate ultimately about the
school thing we have rights I mean we
have our parental rights to say you're
not talking to my kid and if we don't
have the insight into our own behavior
that maybe there's something we could
learn about it then that leaves the the
children in a loop right now as far as
being able to get help so it can't you
just get a warrant because there's so
much more that has to happen in the
meantime so because it is there are many
cases where they decide to not
criminally press charges because you
know say your okay we'll say my say my
um parent used to take a switch from the
backyard which they didn't by the way
but take a switch and hit me and leave
wels on me and I think well this is a
great way to parent so I pass this down
to my kids because I'm I turned out
pretty good so I want to pass this on
well we understand now with our new um
way of looking at abuse and what is good
you know what is proper parenting what
is abusive uh that this isn't the way so
then maybe dcyf just has a conversation
and says did you understand this is not
appropriate you know that happened to
you so there are different levels of
things but that would not necessarily be
founded abuse it would just be a case
where the parenting was a
little not as if that makes sense um it
does make some sense I'm just trying to
I I I'm just trying to understand
zooming out to this big picture so our
entire thing entire system of all the
non-criminal charges is entirely based
on voluntary compliance and all a parent
who's concerned about is to say instead
of the normal thing of I have nothing to
hide so I'm going to speak with you to
that they're only that at this point
their protection of their rights is to
deny that initial
engagement representative cor so as far
as far as I understand in most cases yes
now I'm not expert in this we only know
you know what testimony we get and stuff
the difference is sometimes you have
parents who are divorced and so you'll
have one the other parent pushing it
which means that there's going to be
more of a look into it but they're able
to then talk to that child uh because
they have access from the one parent so
there are different aspects you know
every family situation is incredibly
different and that's why it's always so
important to look at this like there's
no one-size fits all there's no black
and white situation on this but there
are cases where there might be a
guardian there might be somebody else
that has access to the child to where
they can do more of an
investigation representative web and
just to follow on to that I mean the two
big ones are um uh teachers daycare
providers who make are make reports when
they see bruises or other things that
are of anxiety a child who's coming in
who isn't particularly clean um a child
who who you know has whatever is going
on they have to report that so that's
one source and that can of course in in
the case of a parent who is unwilling to
allow access to the child or to the home
that's one source for uh both
information for a warrant if somebody
believes it rises to criminal activity
but that's a whole different proceeding
or it is grounds for the affidavit that
a
DCF cpsw certified professional social
worker will use for the affidavit to
start an abuse and neglect to petition
so teachers are one aspect uh relatives
and um um community members are the
other ones that are very likely to be a
reporting party and and a cooperating
witness I saw somebody yank the child by
his arm and his shoulder looked like it
was you know whatever they saw whatever
they observed so so those are ways that
things get reported and get started as
an inquiry but it's really important to
remember that there's a huge difference
between the
criminal investigation on the one hand
and a dcyf abuse neglect Which is far
more limited in what they can do and
what they have access to so in terms of
the concerns about parents rights I mean
they're cpsws are not allowed to just
storm into your house without your per
permission and if that is happening then
we we need to know about it um and then
the last point that I wanted to try not
to forget is that one of the things that
I think we talked about in the past and
that has come up again is the
playay between parents who are divorcing
and DCF and some of the time a divorcing
parent is divorcing because they are
very concerned about the behavior of the
other parent and rightly so and
sometimes it's
because
um a a parent has decided to weaponize
DCF and the DCF process and again just
as
that there is that tension
between oh did we take a kid out of the
house too soon or did we leave a kid in
the house too long there's also that
tension about is this one of these cases
where um a parent a child is genuinely
in danger or a parent is weaponizing
dcyf and like the Serenity Prayer the
hard part is the wisdom to know the
difference and we are calling on
incredibly caring individuals to try and
make that determination and that's often
the really hard part um so with that and
the divorce ones would it make sense to
sort of think of them as um having DCF
involved for a protective reason or
having them involved as a strategic
reason just to sort of have it in our
mindset to think in divorce there's
either a protective reason or a
strategic reason well I I think that's
how how the divorcing parent is using
them yes I I think that's a very
accurate description and it could blur
at times I recognize too so um at least
if we have that nomenclature to be able
to look at these when there's a divorce
involved and and I think that that also
informs as we go
forward um the testimony that you will
take in the public portion of the
um hearing we got a little blurred in
some of the earlier hearings about all
kinds of different proceedings that
involve parents and courts and so I
think that at this point it's it's our
time to focus very clearly on um those
times if we're talking about uh divorce
courts we're talking about those two
kinds of procedures specifically we're
not talking globally about people's
divorces which is a whole another can of
worms yes thank you um I had had
representative panck then representative
wner then representative Cal
thank you chairman um what I like to be
able to tease out with the committee
work that we're doing is right now we
have a system that um we have family
court is based on hearsay evidence
rather than on fact-based
evidence and when you're going through a
very contentious
divorce sometimes you will
hear about these attorneys that will
advise their clients to make a false
claim in order to remove the child from
the father's custody or whatever I know
of several cases and personally it's
touched my family um so criminal
criminal law is based on
facts where family court is based on
heay evidence how do we fix that that's
where I think things are getting
convoluted um thank you so I think
that's also one of the issues of where
then we get to the court procedures and
that is pro that's something more for
the special committee on the family
court for those court procedures but
that does also come back to the due
process and the fact that if you're not
able to confront your accuser are those
sort of questions too so this is where
it sort of blurs the lines if that's an
response representative Weber that
that's correct and I think the other
thing is that if there is an attorney
out there who is advising a client to
make false claims that should be
reported to the attorney's conduct
Commission because that is never
appropriate conduct for an attorney so
if if there are people who are doing it
that's grounds for attorney discipline
entirely outside of the court
system representative Ware yes um so I I
have missed a couple of meetings so I
may have a little catching up to do here
um but one question I have is as we
proceed are we going to have the
Department of Health and Human Services
specifically DCF come in and talk to us
and walk through some of the proceed
procedures and be an opportunity for us
to ask them questions about the
procedures and how they how they how
they handle these cases thank you that's
a great question that is absolutely one
of the key goals of this committee um
with their change between the current
DCF director leaving and now having an
interim that makes it more challenging
but it also may give us a good
opportunity because nobody was here who
was making those decisions so sometimes
it's a little bit easier to look back
and check somebody else's work when it's
not your work that's being checked um
but I think that's also a reason why we
need to make sure we're focused on the
policies and not the people so we can
look at the policies and what the
policies are and how they protect
without getting too personalized and
making it um be too emotional so that we
can actually get to the fact so we can
protect families going
forward yes so I'm also hoping that you
will invite the child advocate and um
the staff in the child advocate's office
to talk about what they're seeing um yes
thank you my hope would be that um for
scheduling a meeting next week hopefully
we can get the office of the child
advocate in and they can start getting
us some of the information about the
complaints that they receive um and then
also reach out to dcyf in order to get
them to come in and also let us know
about what that complaint procedure is
and what they're seeing as well um and
also whatever policies they do have
specifically that they see I think a lot
of this if we start looking at sort of
the intake as people are first being
introduced to this process and
evaluating the due process there then
it'll be easier as we move forward as
well so thank you representative Kofa
and then representative
long thank you so you know we've we've
heard several comments about the
distinction between a criminal case and
a um a case of abuse and neglect um
which is a
crime yet I guess my concern is that if
you look at this from the perspective of
a parent who is under investigation or
potentially under
investigation um it's a distinction with
very little difference um if you are
being deprived of a liberty interest if
you are being deprived of your
children potentially
as we heard one person um I I believe we
heard one person testify I would you
know I I would rather go to jail than to
have my children taken out of my
home
um fundamental rights are not something
that we negotiate away when there's an
emergency or an you know something
especially important and and so this is
my concern is that there is a
um there there's a point at which I
think we need to establish that
fundamental rights are fundamental
rights
period
um to me it does seem that a
warrant is is appropriate under certain
circumstances it it may be appropriate
that we need a a faster more efficient
process for that um but I would also
point out that the process I I I have
heard from constituents about cases
where the process itself was harmful to
the child um in cases where um there was
the child was not taken out of the home
there was a threat that the child was
going to be removed from the home there
were very very lengthy inexpensive Court
proceedings and the finding was that
there's no finding here there's you know
there's no fault here
um in that case that child is still
experiencing Trauma from the process
so so the trauma to the child Cuts both
ways I think a a process in which a
warrant is required does a couple of
things one is that um it puts the
breakes on that potential
scenario um another is that I think it
puts the breakes on this
weaponization of dcyf and and reports I
spoke to another constituent who said
well you know my uh my my boyfriend's
ex-wife um does not make false reports
but always seems to have conversations
with people who are mandatory reporters
and
um she's made you know something like 20
reports so far and 20 out of 20 have
been found to have absolutely no basis
in fact um this is consuming bandwidth
this is consuming bandwidth for
DCF um investigators who um quite
honestly um have a lot to do we keep
hearing that um they are they have very
burdensome Cas loads um
and in every case they've kind of come
out of this saying yep we we understand
what's really going on here there we we
have found that there is no finding and
yet dcyf has said you know we cannot
assign the same person to you know to to
this case that was on it last time so I
I I guess I you know my my concern is
that we recognize that fundamental
rights constitutional rights are are in
our constitution because they they are
that important and so to me it seems
that this discussion
about um about warrants is I I I hear
that side I I am offering the other side
which is I I I really don't think that
that is something that we can negotiate
away if we're talking about due process
here
I'm representative long and then
representative Weber thank you madam
chair uh I I would just caution us to
keep separate dcyf in courts because I I
think we're going to Cloud up the
subject we're focused on DCF let's let's
see it and I think there's plenty uh
with respect to Du uh diligence that uh
we've already discussed that we could
look into um and again we're we're all
uh mandatory mandatory reporters and I
know speaking with DC YF that I think
the number was 10 the same person
filing complaints uh they talk with that
person um I don't know if there's
anything further they could do uh you
know could they charge that person with
falsifying I don't know what that love
of bar is um and with respect to
warrants again the DCF uh doesn't get
warrant um it's Criminal court that gets
the warrants representative Weber but
but to follow on to representative long
and representative Coal's comments
although they don't start with warrants
unless they're calling the police
because there's criminal stuff that
needs to be investigated right now what
does happen is that a DCF proceeding in
the court so I'm just talking about the
DCF
proceedings start with three
hearings one right after the other the
first is a preliminary hearing and
that's really in the nature of what
would be called a probable cause hearing
in a criminal case it's where the
department has to present by
affidavit
their uh case for why this is a case of
abuse and neglect and it gets then
reviewed by a judge so that's the
preliminary then this and and at all of
these there is an appointed attorney for
the parents so the parents are not
standing there with no counsel at all
second there's an adjudicatory hearing
at which the department has the burden
of
proving
that abuse or neglect has happened and
that's entirely on the department the
parent does doesn't have to present
anything the department has to make that
case and then the third hearing is
called a dispositional hearing and that
is the hearing at
which uh both parties uh present
evidence should they choose to do so
they're often done by agreement of the
parties but um and a plan is made you
know these thing steps have to be taken
for this child to be kept safe and that
may be removal from the home
it may be keeping the child in the home
and it may be evaluations by
professionals whatever it could be but
that plan is then set out after that
third hearing and then there is a
further hearing every three months for a
year for the parents to
comply with the conditions that were
either set out by the court or agreed to
by the parents to ensure that the child
is being kept safe or that um you know
the parents making good progress or
they're not making any progress and and
so there's Court oversight all the way
through and then it's not till the end
of an entire year that if in fact the
parents are not
progressing you have an entirely
separate proceeding called determination
of parental rights if you get to that
point
but with any luck we haven't gotten to
that point but but there are cases where
that's necessary so there's a lot of
process already built in and and I think
understanding that is helpful so
although yes there aren't warrants there
is an early
review um and
um that's one of the many places where a
report could be unfounded I mean
sometimes you report it to dcyf and they
say yeah that's not abuse and that's not
neglect go home the second would be they
do an investigation and say we can't
substantiate any of the things that were
said in which case they have to close
the case um and it's not till after that
happens so those two could be unfounded
for those reasons um and then if you go
to court sometimes the court say says G
if this is your best shot cpsw this does
not amount to U abuse neglect and we're
going to dismiss your
petition um thank you so my first
question would be in those preliminary
hearings um who is the appointed
attorney paid paid by
um the parent if the parent has assets
and um uh appointed I guess by the
judicial Council if they
don't and sorry and then is a J judicial
councel part of the family court process
or is it separate and outside of
separate it's sort of a an an adjunct to
the court system but it's
it's it's the arm that is charged with
providing attorneys for people who can't
afford them sorry okay and then if the
parents able to pay it's still an
appointed attorney that who they then
pay for that's been recommended if a
parent is paying for an attorney they
can pick whoever they want to pick okay
so I think this is probably something
that um I want to dig into this and the
specifics about that appointed attorney
what ecosystem that works in if that
funding stream is tied to the other
funding streams and to understand
because one of the big trends that came
through all of it was having the
independence because if you're too close
together in this process then that that
could have the potential of appearance
of conflict of interest and we want to
make sure that's not the case and I'll
just I'll just say as an answer to that
um the cases that I know about which is
not many um the the attorneys who are
appointed have been attorneys who are
attorneys in private practice they're
they're not some and I don't know if it
may be different in other places but
where in my part of the state it's an
attorney who is in private practice who
has made themselves available for this
kind of work but it is not they're not
contracted you know their whole
livelihood does not come from this they
they have an independent practice and so
with that we'll probably want to look
into their independent contractor status
just like how the um IRS if you do too
much of your work with somebody doesn't
see you as independent so I'd be curious
what the percentage of these cases are
for these attorneys representive Greg
thank you madam chairwoman I think
another thing um important to remember
is we have legislation that's been
moving through the house this year on
both the um uh false reporting making
that more of a a criminal charge and
then also I think that's already passed
through I don't know where that's at in
the Senate we have a bill that passed
through the house and now we have the
Senate bill with the same thing getting
representation for um minors who are at
risk of being removed from their homes
so that's another level so as we're
looking into some of these things um
it's good to keep in mind What
legislation is already happening that we
have already seen issues and we're
working on um trying to remedy some of
those situations so some of these
problems are already in process of
getting looked at uh thank you and also
looking at everything else we have in
progress making sure it's headed in the
right direction as well um that my
question is about as we move to
termination of parental rights I know
that there um was Federal legislation
under Clinton which spoke to the amount
of time somebody could be in foster care
before they were removed do we know how
long that termination of parental rates
happens takes once it comes into play
representative Weber well the federal
requirements are that a parent have a
year
to
comply and and and to make the changes
necessary for a child to be at home
unsupervised I know that the trend and I
don't have statistics on this but I know
that the trend
has been over the last eight or 10 years
that I've been involved in various ways
with these issues is for fewer children
to be removed from their
homes and so fewer children either
institutionalized or in foster care and
that's for whole bunches of reasons none
of which I'm an expert on uh but
um a
parent has has that right and and there
there are times when you can speed a
case up because it's really stagnating
because the child deserves a safe home
and there are times when you slow it
down because typically the reason they
get slowed down is a parent is in
treatment for substance abuse they are
making good progress they are going to
their meetings they are submitting to
drug screening they are working hard and
their sobriety is still fragile enough
that being being a full-time
unsupervised parent with all of the
stress that that brings is not they're
not ready yet but it's recognized by
everybody that they're progressing
towards so it's sort of a onee but as in
everything with this one size never fits
all so U thank you and so one of the
things that I want us to research I'll
get to representative love next is um as
I was reading some of these it seems
that some of the federal funding is tied
to the amount of time until the child is
removed from the home and that if this
doesn't happen on a certain timeline
it's implicated um so I'd like to find
out this this was in some of the
reporting from some of some of the other
states if we prove that that's not the
case here then great we have more
information however under the um it was
stated that it was under the adoption
and safe families act um so you know
either we either we show what the
numbers are or we show that it's not a
concern either way it would be good to
have that information well I think I
think that that that is specifically
what I was referring
to what the federal legislation the goal
of the federal legislation is ensuring
that a child is not stuck in limbo
forever because we are balancing the
fundamental rights of the parent and the
fundamental rights of the child and um
so the goal of the federal legislation
is to ensure that in the cases where
parents are not making progress and the
child is already out of the home that
the child starts to progress towards
adoption at the end of a year um it if
if the child is in the home I think that
we're really just looking at a different
scenario thank you and I think we can
probably all agree that if the intention
of our bills were what actually happened
we'd have a lot less legislation we'd
have to do so we do want to make sure
that those any financial implications
are not leading to a different
implementation that was intended
representative love yeah to to bring it
back uh to what representative kofalt
and representative Greg who talked about
the the procedures that go on in in um
in dcyf the latitude that they have uh
is is just too too great um when uh for
instance if I if I decided to go a
little crazy and jump across the table
and punch representative long it's a
criminal criminal act but if he's if
he's five years old in my home and I
punch him it's a dcyf investigation they
don't have the they don't have the
investigative
skills that you know a detective would
have uh that they come in and this is
what I I get from from constituents you
know that they come in and uh you know
the the especially when most of them are
are divorce cases going on but they'll
they'll uh invest they'll question the
child with the father and then they'll
you know our father or mother whatever
uh but then they'll then they'll
question them again in front of the the
the abuser and uh what 5-year-old child
isn't going to cow it to that you know
uh you know representative Greg
mentioned the broken bones you know many
times I've heard from constituents no
broken bones no hospitalization there
isn't much we can do that's a common
common thing that they say and uh that's
way too much latitude if a child has
been punched it's a criminal thing and
uh you know uh we've got to put we've
we've got to make sure that that that
that Latitude is really shrunk because
uh it's it's a lot of where our problem
is lied I mean poor Hy Montgomery you
know sitting there in the backseat of a
car in the middle of February with her
with their two siblings you know and um
you know Mom and Dad are s mom and uh
stepmom and dad are sitting in the front
car front seat of the car shooting dope
where do we draw the line my God you
know um you know this is this just and
representative kofalt talked about you
know it it could be a a lot has to do
with you know there just the the workers
overburdened that you know the got a
stack of cases on the on their desk that
high uh but uh we've got to find the
find find the way to to uh to get this
done right that is a great Point
representative love um as I was looking
through the criminal statutes assault of
a child under 13 is treated more
severely than assault of an adult um so
one of the questions that then we would
have is how is the decision made if um
to either refer for criminal prosecution
which I would say that that physical
assault physical assault of a child
should I would say should be criminal um
and when it's decided not to not to be
pursued that way and to be pursued under
DCF so I'd like to know what what those
lines are and what those processes are
and if it's something where perhaps we
need to have more resources to the
prosecutors in order to deal with these
cases because if they're just worried
about a low referral rate and a low
uptake rate then we we have the power to
work with others to fix that U
representative Weber and then
representative Greg and I think you're
right about all of that but I think that
the um it it it's important to remember
it's not an either or the two things may
be happening at the same time that's
that's number one and number two the
problem with the criminal prosecution is
you have to have as as representative
Panic said you have to have evidence you
have to have evidence in a in a DCF case
as well uh but if if you have a child
with a bruise and somebody says so and
so punch the child and and so and so
saying no I didn't you have to be able
to prove what happened and and that may
have an impact on the low rates of
criminal prosecution but I think that
it's definitely an area for
exploration representative
Greg thank you madam chairman I think
another part that you know we talk a lot
about the physical injuries and the
broken bones and stuff but one of uh
dcf's uh biggest challenges and one of
uh the things that they have to look at
is also the environment the child's in
because abuse things aren't always like
well he got hit or whatever it could be
you know the psychological Terror from
maybe um you know Mom was strangling dad
and the child was witnessed to that
there are different there are different
levels even within that or um you know
maybe they're
um allowed to play with a real gun
instead of a a play gun you know there
are different levels that dcyf has to
look at and so not all of those that
goes back to that switch thing not all
of these are criminal so there's this
you know waving when dcyf as soon as
they see that it is a criminal thing
such as assault that's when it goes to
you know the police and the police can
do their investigations and stuff but
first there are so many other things
that dcyf has to look at whether it's
you know doing drugs in front of kids um
you know uh not feeding them you know
for for a a time period or you know
restricting them to a cage even you know
there are so many other things that
they're looking at that isn't
necessarily a physical thing so it's a
very complicated spectrum of things I
think it'll be great to actually get
them in here and hear firsthand the kind
of things in New Hampshire that they're
looking at because the things that we
think are just on the news and other
places they're absolutely in our
backyard um thank you and if putting a
child in a cage is not already criminal
statute let's work together and make it
so that that is for false imprisonment
um and I know it's quite possible that
it is U so with that I would like to
know what the referral rate is and then
what the actual rate of um it BR
prosecuted and then sort of what the
outcomes are for that because if we
don't have enough resources in our
criminal system and we're allowing
people
to commit physical crimes against kids
that's a big problem and one we should
solve um representative Weber I'll just
add that you know historically I mean
one of the things that's that's
difficult about this is It's a moving
Target now I think things have been
moving in the right direction but
historically I mean I can remember it's
it's only been within the last 8 to 10
years for example that having drug
paraphernalia all over the house was
allowed to be considered as a factor in
abuse and neglect prior to that the
child actually had to either ingest
something or stick themselves with
something before that was allowable and
it seems axiomatic to me that we
shouldn't have to wait until the child
is actually injured uh but as
recently as about 10 years ago that
wasn't even a consideration so uh it's
it's important to recognize the rate of
change the other thing that has been
interesting to me historically is that
eight or 10 years ago we fought and
fought and fought to get more positions
with DCF because the um case workers
were carrying rate case loads that were
five or six times the best practices
average now we have those positions and
the challenges finding people to
actually fill the existing positions so
in some ways we're back in that same
bind we were talking about the issue of
uh needing to have enough workers to to
deal with the workload so we're we're
back in the same position but it's from
a different
reason thank you those are definitely
good points um so representative oh did
you have something repres yes I just
want to address one thing to uh Vice
chair we just SP uh spent some time on
children and family law committee and we
just passed unanimously in our committee
um to expand
dcf's
ability um for personnel so it's going
into Finance so we are looking at that
but we've got to put some rins on it too
which we did it's always a moving T
right thank you for your work on that um
thank you and and then my other question
becomes at what point does compliance
with DCF process when it's not criminal
stop being voluntary because it seems
that cooperating with them at all in the
first place is voluntary when does that
move from voluntary to compelled with a
consequence if they do not follow
through representative Weber well if I'm
understanding your
question um and I was thinking about
this in context of something you raised
earlier in another meeting about drug
testing
um basically everything a parent does
DCF um
well it's it's it's how you look at
voluntary and I realize there are very
different shades of voluntary and
they're ve very different shades of
coercion if for example somebody is
undergoing a drug test as a part of a
drug
court uh they either take the test or
they go to jail it's very simple uh
because they were either because they
were adjudicated or because they agreed
to that as part of their Criminal
sentence in DCF
cases um
the a parent is not compelled to do a
drug test for example but I think
there's a great deal of room for
discussion of how coercive it is when
you say to somebody this is to to
representative kof's point this is what
you have to do or you're not going to
get your children back or this is what
you have to do and or you're going to
have your children taken away there's a
great deal of coercion there
but that's what the consequence is um
you you come up with the plan in the
dispositive hearing and the parent
either voluntarily follows the plan in
which
case they're working towards disengaging
with dcyf and and you know you I have a
final hearing where the judge says
you're doing a great job thank you um or
or you proceed with some other
proceeding
but
so in that context things are voluntary
but in that context there is also
coercion involved
so
um it's not something
that has an easy answer thank you
representative long thank you m chair so
uh when uh representative Weber
discussed the uh procedures dcy
procedures I would think that at the
dispositional hearing where both parties
present evidence that's when it wouldn't
be voluntary if you want to defend
yourself you have to present your
evidence um so that I think at that
voluntar uh thank you so it' be
voluntarily up to then
it can be okay and so within that
process that if it's voluntary through
then there's no way to remove the child
until You' reach the dispositional
hearing child can be removed exp parte
so without court hearing if there's an
immediate danger a court can be removed
at the preliminary hearing a court can
be removed at the adjudicatory hearing
and the child can be removed If the
child was left with the parent the the
child can always be removed if if it
turns out that that was not a safe
placement that happen that can happen
anywhere along the
line but that's a question of immed
safety of the
child okay thank you and that's not a
criminal statute right and none of this
is criminal in nature so but you're
removing a child which is one of which
is a significant liberty interest right
so within this in both directions in
both directions yes but you have this
process and it seems that the what I'm
seeing most of the protections of due
process are the fact that you don't have
to comply except if you don't comply
your child is taken I'm trying to
understand this no well my classical
understanding of due process is here's
what the process is first of all
somebody has to file an
affidavit uh secondly the court does a
preliminary review and the court so that
is a component of due process you have
an independent review by an independent
magistrate of what is presented to the
magistrate and the parent can if they
wish present or doesn't have
to then you get the second point which
is the adjudicatory hearing which
again the burden of proof is all on DCF
to prove that there was abuse or neglect
or the case is dismissed so that is due
process part of the due process is that
the parent has the right to an attorney
so they are given counsel as well as the
two hearings and then when you get to
the third hearing about we we have an
adjudication then the next question is
um what what is the plan going
forward so thank you so I guess within
that the probably Key Stone of this is
that it's an independent review Court
review of the affidavit the independence
of those two bodies AB absolutely okay
um and so with that I'd like to and as
you said the independent nature of the C
quality of the council provided if it's
not of the parents choosing okay so I
think that's actually going to be a very
important thing for us to dig into as
well the independence of all of these
different sections um but I I I guess
now that we're representative
Cal yeah again I'm going to I'm going to
offer what is sort of anecdotal
information but I think it merits
further investigation which is you know
among the due process rights listed in
one of the documents you shared is the
right to be heard and we have heard this
somewhat repeated in in other forms
throughout this discussion which is is
that a a parent who has been accused has
a right
to present evidence a right to be heard
in court um so the anecdotal information
is that I have heard from at least two
people who have said that they did not
have an opportunity to present the
evidence that they had prepared and the
expert witnesses that they had brought
with them to court that's a concern that
to me is a is a violation of due process
and I know that we have said that we
don't want to um you know we need to
focus on DCF not the courts I agree and
yet um there is an end to-end process
here and we need to consider the
implications on due process um for for
the person who's going through this
experience and and not just say well um
you know we'll throw it over to the
other side of the wall and then it's the
court it's it's the courts issue um we
we need to I mean our our job is to
understand um if there are um breakdowns
in due process where are they and what
would this committee recommend to remedy
those thank you representative Greg um
thank you madam chairwoman so I also sit
on the special com uh committee looking
at the family courts we've actually
addressed that specifically um somebody
not being able to uh give you know
everything that they think and and and
why so we had a bill at least having the
judges kind of like explain um but
that's something that the special
committee on family courts I I do
believe that that's where that belongs
and we've kind of addressed that so
those are pretty complicated but just
wanted to let you know that um thank you
do you know the status of that because
as a bill it'll be going over to the
Senate and we need to make sure we can't
check it off the list until it becomes
lost I do not know I know that there's
there's some ongoing issues with that
one that we're kind of um looking into
so I don't I think that I think it did
pass through the house did it not yeah I
thought it also yeah yeah I think it
pass through the house and fin with the
family court yeah so it'll be with that
special committee but that's something
specifically that we looked at because
we did hear cases where people thought
that they didn't get enough information
and and and that's one of those cases
where with each case it's very
individual and that's the judicial
branch like we have to be very careful
where there's a separation of the
branches in the judicial branch they you
know we're looking at judicial training
are they trained properly to be able to
do all this so that's something that we
can look at but when it comes to their
discretion we have to make sure that
we're not um overlapping on their
discretion in their particular court is
because somebody could bring in I mean
years of things that they think is
relevant because they're trying to do
whatever so we have to I mean if you
think about you know well I feel really
strongly about something so I'm going to
give you 5,000 witnesses that can say
that saw me smile at this point I'm not
you know all these different things so
that's a really um I I see uh
representative kof's point and we did
talk about that at Great length but it's
everything with families is complicated
this is another one of those but there
is certainly a separation between the
branches here that we have to
acknowledge thank you um I think that's
a good point but I think we need to also
make sure we have a list of all of these
things that are critical to the due
process even if it's being done
underneath another committee that we
continue to follow up and make sure that
that's moving forward and watch it
through the entire process because we
could weigh in as a special committee to
ensure that this is passed all the way
and becomes law because this does seem
to be an absolutely critical
underpinning so I think that interface
would be appropriate representative
Weber well if you're keeping your list
and I again it's overstepping on several
committees here but the lack of judicial
resources is very much an issue here and
when you have a court that has scheduled
a hearing and this is in every single
kind of court case I'm thinking of the
probate courts as well um when there's
one hour and somebody has taken up 45
minutes to present one side of a case
then you get 15 minutes and then the
court says well I have to stop now and
you can come back a month from now and
that is incredibly frustrating to the
litigant and it is something that
that the only way of addressing that is
more Court resources so that's a whole
different ball of wax but it has a huge
effect on um individual litigants and
how they perceive the system and how the
system actually acts in their cases so
just keep it in the back of our minds
it's not our Bailey Wick but it's one of
those things that has a huge impact on
exactly the sorts of things that we're
talking about here uh thank you and that
brings up the issue of siloing if we
always say something think somebody
else's job it gets to be a challenge so
if we know where to follow up with
others it's good to make sure that
nothing's dropped representative
kofalt thank you so um first of all I
think that is a very good point we do
hear that a lot about um Court
resources um just to follow up on the
the bill that you mentioned that is H
Bill
475 um it did go over to the Senate it
was had a hearing in Senate
Judiciary uh who recommended interim
study and we'll go to the senate floor
on
Thursday so I guess that it was it was a
five to nothing vote in judiciary thank
you that's helpful but disappointing
information so it seems that this is not
yet handled so we should make sure that
the Senate will be working on this and
hopefully the special committee on the
Family Court will be working with them
to make sure that they understand the
importance of this representative long
yeah and just uh briefly uh there's
amendments coming forward which can add
that fantastic we know we know how to
work the process as well as the other
body that makes me feel good thank
you okay thank you I think we've had
some great conversation great dialogue
and I think we move forward in this with
some areas to look into I will follow up
with inviting people in with information
um but with that um I'm going to close
our work session and um and then we will
sorry long standing is my cough for a
long time after I get better so with
this I will open up the regular
committee where we will be hearing from
members of the public um so first I want
to set just a couple of
expectations um guard rails guidelines
as we do this if you've never spoken in
front of a committee like this before it
can be a little more than you're
expecting before you sit down at the
microphone um and for that I would ask
anybody who hasn't done this before to
let me know and I'm going to give you
two minutes just to start getting your
feet and then we'll pause see if that's
see where you are if you're if you're
moving forward pretty well and how
you're saying this um might want to give
you some feedback on how best to present
yourself because I know that some people
when they come up and they speak for a
long time it gets to be kind of
challenging I've been in that seat
before many times um so this is in order
to be supportive so we'll let you know
after about 2 minutes and then then to
be able to continue on
we are not saying names this is about
the policies this is about the
procedures this is about making sure
that everything as we move forward is
done correctly um if we get into blaming
any particular people then it's going to
be a lot harder to actually fix it
because when somebody gets blamed they
dig in their heels and they don't want
to admit they' they've done anything
wrong um that's not going to get any of
us to the solution that we want um and
so for that I ask that you keep names
out of it um so that we can fix things
um as opposed to getting getting stuck
in more of a accusatory phase um so and
I know that it can be emotional so this
time we brought some tissues if anybody
needs them because it can be C up there
especially when you're talking about
something as personal and important as
your life um and if you need to pause it
all you can pause when you're speaking
um because this is recorded on YouTube
it will be there if you have any open
cases or anything else this is public
information and as members of the public
your speech here is not protected the
same way that legislator speech is
protected so speak generally don't give
us information that will cause harm to
you or to your family um so with that um
I would like to welcome up anamarie
deato if she's not here that's our no
that's all right I can grab the next
person and get her but if you want to
let her know um okay um Eric
Blair okay now we ready yet not a
problem I'm happy to push people back
this is a different experience for
people skip Murphy you've asked for
three
minutes and I know you're a pro at this
amateur that would
fit um I'm glad to see that a lot of
time was spent on the EXP parte uh issue
as representative Weber brought up and
described the process
in very good
detail my personal
entanglements uh with DCF often times
have had the EXP parte at which point
the parents if this was a reality TV Jim
kofalt has put it their the Liberty
issue is the removal of their child from
them now maybe some of those parents
understood maybe they
didn't I think that that is something
something that really needs a lot of
looking at when it comes to the due
process and I know that representative
Greg mentioned uh the bill that is going
through uh Jim said HB 475 I'm not
familiar with it I'm going to look at it
because that's I'm a wonk at some point
still not a professional
representatively
um also I think that the big deal that
really needs to be looked at is what is
that dividing line between voluntary and
coercion because everybody who gets
involved in this as a parent it's like
the IRS we can put you in jail and take
your
money as far as DCF is concerned we'll
just take something that's even more
valuable to you in most cases which is
your child and yes I understand there
are parents out there who could care
less about their child I run into them
so there's always the good there's
always the bad as I said in the first
hearing this is a bipartisan issue
there's going to be good and bad on both
sides but it's all should always be
about the
child I will let you know and I know my
three minutes is coming to an
end a lot of the training that my wife
and I have taken voluntarily talks about
the trauma to the child of what has
happened
before and also
what goes on during the placement of
that child with one or more foster
parents it is very obvious that the kids
get scared and then they get numbed oh I
have to go somewhere else I'm being
moved to another foster home it may be
because of their behavior and it may
just be the foster parents have said
there's other things going on in our
lives we can't do that but I think that
also needs a little due process for the
child and represent of Greg to your
point about getting a lawyer appointed
for the
child the situations that I have been in
and we have just started our fifth
entanglement is that a guardian medle
item is is appointed usually from the
ranks of Casa to represent that child in
all uh legal proceedings
and I will tell you that in the last one
the weight of her testimony and her line
of questioning during the
hearings was such that the child got a
lot more services intensive Services
than what otherwise would have happened
so I think it's a good thing that it
comes foremost but it's also already
covered and I just bring that up I'm
assuming that you already know about the
G's and the work of C
so I'm not quite sure where the the
actual lawyer part comes in because the
gal's that I've run into they are
vociferous they do not hold back in
court which is a good thing and with
that thank you thank you very much are
there any are you taking questions if
there are any sure absolutely although I
don't I don't see any sorry to make you
sit back down but thank you very much I
appreciate
that um an Marie
deato so I just so since you weren't in
the room when I was first giving the
information um if you want to sit down
make yourself comfortable and I'll just
tell you sort of some of what we set up
just to make it easier for people who
haven't testified before um have you
come in and testified before the
legislature much before um then I'm
going so what we're doing is we're not
discussing names we're discussing the
policies if you have anything that's
active um just be careful about what
information you share because what you
say here is um what you say here is
public it's recorded it will be on
YouTube
uh but it's important to get information
out here so that you can have the
information and share it with uh share
what we need to know about the policies
um that are impacting you which are why
you're here since you haven't spoken
before I'm going to give you two minutes
just to sort of get your footing then
I'll have you pause take a deep breath
and then we'll figure out how much more
time you want to continue just because
staring at a 10-minute block of times a
lot and just want to make sure that you
have all the support and encouragement
that you can have right here so with
that um I'm going to let you start up
with h two minutes start getting some
information to us and then we'll pause
so thank you I S to tell the whole truth
God my name is Anna Marie jamato and um
my situation relationship experience
with
DCF um came where um it was a very brief
they have been they've checked in on me
for
um my son's lead was high and I missed
the doctor's appointment um but in any
event so I've had and then um the
neighbor's cat got out and my son was
chasing around the backyard so a couple
of these cases well nothing had gone
founded correct um so I'll just leading
you up to I had a guardianship case with
my family which closed and upon that
closing the guardian at Lighting in that
closing um and I had discussed there
being a voluntary case opened with DCF
and that was part of the Clause to close
the guardianship so the Guardians ship
was closed and lo and behold DCF
screamed it out and didn't open a
voluntary case with me now I this comes
because you know I mean I'm a single mom
and my son at the time
was three three to four and it had been
just him and I all day like all day
every day and so I was I was certainly
taxed um I had a really hard time
finding Child Care uh I don't want to
get too far off from this but I just so
I just um want to explain or tell you so
there was I could have used some help
some networking some some whatever their
services were um supposed to be I
certainly probably could have used that
my case or whatever and so there there
was no case so I'm gonna you're two
minutes in you're doing an amazing job
so keep keep going I'll give you another
seven minutes to keep talking you're
doing
you I didn't mean to knock you off what
you were saying you're amazing you're a
rock star taking care of your son and
doing all of this and I'm really sorry
that DCF didn't give you the supports
you were asking for so me too after you
take a deep breath let us know what you
happened so then uh let's see in May a
so my son turned five in April of
2021 and he got a bite for his
birthday and at the time I lived on a
class six Road in starter not one car
would drive by during the day other you
know quite
remote and I felt confident and secure
in letting him ride his bike um and so
and and that was apparent I grew up in
Vermont and I you know was glad to be in
sted and and raising my son in
environment as close as as as I could to
my own so my son
um dcy was called because my son was
found riding his bike without me then he
was found you know and so then I get a
visit from
DCF and there there
were also I'm sorry we call it a race
car of a brain my son has the same thing
as I do and we don't really call it what
it is but that's a true statement we
both have that so pardon me for that um
stacking wood one day and I you know
just blow my arms up with wood and I
turned around and he's gone now he was
down at sand pile which was you know
less than 20 yards away from me in any
event um I wasn't scared I wasn't scared
I knew he he was close by he can't run
faster than I can and you know but
whatever he was doing he thought that he
could utilize something somewhere else
and so you know he was gone it wasn't um
a neglect on my part
it wasn't um a conscious parenting
Choice even though my parenting style
is off from what you know the general
streamline is but I had put a lot of
time into my parenting style having
wanted a child for so long and not being
able to have one and having one like I
was blessed with that so it didn't it's
not like on a whim all my parenting
choices like I I haven't tension with my
parenting but they didn't hear that they
just heard I'm not going to be a
helicopter parent and and you know that
I had my an alternative parenting style
and so in any event um the this is why
DC was called was because of my son and
and now mind you um we'd put alarms on
the doors i' installed video cameras in
in inside and outside my home um we took
away his bike uh we were we had a
conversation with him um but I was
taking the steps that any other parent
or family would take to rectify this
issue you know I had been already going
to a parenting U group and and support
for the ters and and and such and so I
wasn't the only one that has having this
problem at five years old like and it
was a topic of discussion in fact the
very day that they came uh in late May
of
2021 they came the very next day and
with the next parte and they
took I haven't seen my son back in my
home since and I've been fighting really
hard the whole case plan that they had
laid out um were already things that I
had already been doing I told you about
the guardianship case so I had already
had a parenting educator and and a
counselor LC and and
um counselor for the for the a family
for the for the both of us everything
that they had in my case plan I had
already been doing and and case worker
knew it coming to my house he had
already known that I was in all those
things and um he didn't call anybody he
didn't call any one of them
and the judge granted um the EXP parte
now in that X parte you know they they
Supply an affidavit and in that
affidavit um there were 11 statements
and eight of them were not factual and I
could prove in black and white video
hardcore that six so two are like but
six of them black and white hardcore
video I brought it to the courtroom
brought the video footage he said that I
looked and acted a certain way he said
that my son took off three times during
the visit he said all sorts of things
that in this affidavit that got the EXP
factual I thank you you for sharing this
with us and trusting us with this
information I'm so sorry that you've
gone through this and with this process
um so with that it was because your son
was running around going to the sand pit
and playing on your property and the
property adjacent to it that was the
reason why they came for that yes and
because there had
been the guardianship was
was generated by my my family who I had
been arranged from and they we were not
we were not um familiar with each other
andth less I've been in sobriety for at
that time eight years and um in a in a
treatment program but my family didn't
know anything about me being a mom in
sobriety didn't know me they didn't know
anything about me period at that
time so there was
some allegations in history of substance
use which it was included in this
affidavit he said that he saw
paraphernalia which we were able to
prove in black and white video footage
that he did not see paraphernalia in my
home the substance use part of my case
was dropped I won that part for proving
that the case worker lied in you know to
the court yet he's still employed
and um yeah so there so there's there's
more so so there's more to there's that
part however I I did win that part the
substance use part and I continued to go
on random UA throughout their case plan
with me and
uh the tribunal you know the tribunal
court that they have uh my judge is
there's no way that he could be unbiased
so he let me so just more to the facts
about it as opposed to saying that about
so there's more so the facts are that it
remains in a court in the same court
that had heard my 3 n 369 and 12mth
hearing is the same judge who hears your
termination of parental rights
hearing so there's no way that there
can't be a bias there um yeah but we're
here today to talk about Jew process and
and and that affidavit that he provided
was not factual and I proved it in court
continued I'm I'm so sorry for what's
happened with you and your son
um thank you for sharing that
information we need to find out what
happens when an affidavit has um things
that are proven to not be true and to
figure out how that's handled within the
department and um what and what that
process is because we need to understand
how that's handled and as far as due
process it sounds like you believe that
having the termination of parenting
heard by a different judge than the one
who hears your um ongoing ones for the
thing would would give you a better
better feeling that there was due
process because it would be a different
judge no I think it would be better if
there was a jury of my peers if it was
due
process that thank you that that I I
definitely understand to that point
because having a jury of your peers
looking at termination of parenting I
can understand that perspective that
makes a lot of sense um so um sorry
representative
kofalt thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question so you
mentioned um exculpatory evidence you
had on video did you have a full
opportunity to present that evidence in
court yes okay and which is why we why I
won the substance part of the case but
unsupervised today that you know he'
gotten his bike he learned to ride of
that day and and that these are the
things that happen yes those things
happen Okay follow followup um would you
believe that we have a a bill that the
house passed earlier this
year I believe it's House Bill
1012 would establish
that when parents allow children to take
reasonable risks to further their
development as independent human beings
that that would not be a violation of
our child welfare statutes I do follow
and I am familiar and I'm happy
unfortunately that that too is going to
the senate floor on Thursday and it
looks like it's going to go to interim
study but I just wanted to find out if
you're aware of that thank
you thank
you um so thank you so much for sharing
that I I I hope that
um I don't have any words that I can
offer you but just let us let you know
sharing um next Eric Blair are you ready
to come or do you want to let somebody
else come first
okay okay um uh Chris
noise said 10 minutes I know you've been
up before so I'll let the timer will let
you know when 10 minutes is here and if
um if you can keep it a little shorter
than that I we have several people that
leave need to leave at noon so I want to
make sure that everybody can be heard if
you can maybe keep that to maybe seven
minutes or so to my name is Chris noise
um I'm an inhabitant of State of New
Hampshire currently living in Bethlehem
and one thing I wanted to add about Anna
Marie's case cuz she been talking to me
about is that there was a there's an
also an affidavit that she didn't
mention today which was placed by the
DCF worker which was clearly hearsay the
dcyf worker wrote an affidavit stating
that the neighbor saw the child doing
something or other that in and of itself
disqualifies an affidavit affidavit has
to be firsthand knowledge so if dcyf
workers are in the practice of serving
secondhand hearsay
affidavits that should let everybody
know right off the bat that there's
problems and her child winds up being
taken um after the end of a process that
started on a hearsay affidavit is all
wrong but
um I think it's important to talk about
right now the impact that the New York
pistol and rifle versus Brewing case has
had on the way
courts
determine um what a law means so in the
New York pistol and rifle case the
Supreme Court basically shifted the
Paradigm
entirely from the What's called the
two-step method um for reviewing um and
determining what Allah law means and
they shift it to the one-step method and
in this method um what they do is they
restrict thems combine themselves only
to the founding generation's
understanding of a law so basically the
first 50 years
um and
during that during that time um what we
find is that there is no historical
tradition during the founding
generations for removing children for
from a home for going out to play for
instance um but more importantly that
impacts how you define what true do
process is so the definitions that were
brought forward today are from middle
American Juris Prudence or recent
American Juris prudence and like I said
the Supreme Court has ued that and you
can hear the liberal um Supreme Court
Justices actually complaining about that
in the oral arguments of rahimi versus
us where they're saying Are We Now
confined to only being able to look at
the founding generation's understanding
of the written law in order to determine
the the ruling in the case and um the
the finding was that yes that that's how
it goes now for the since uh
22 so that basically takes the ACLU
definitions of due process that you
brought forward now which are from
recent history and at a supreme court
level those would be tossed out what
would be considered the true do process
is what Leah kushman has brought forward
before she was removed from the
committee which is a sworn affidavit has
to kick everything off that has to be
firsthand uh testimony secondly the
person needs to have a true trial by a
jury which is different from a jury
trial and you should look into the
difference and has to move exclusively
by the rule Ru of common law no statute
can be used that is the true historical
tradition of due process in America and
that's part of New Hampshire
Constitution 115 which you all swore
oath to
uphold now also as a result of this
Bruin
decision confining courts confining
themselves to the founding generation's
understanding of how this country
operates um I'm going to leave this I'm
going to leave some uh evidence for you
um but there was a gentleman at the
Buffalo law school scholar who did a re
who did research on some 15,000
documents of all the writings of the
framers and Debaters of the
Constitutions and what he found was that
unanimously every single one of them
whether Federalists or Anti-Federalists
believed that the Constitutions were
public trusts and they said that the the
fiduciary duty of the trustees um who
swear oath to these public trusts the
penalty for violate for breaching trust
should be more severe than those uh the
counterpart breaches and remedies
available or sorry remedies and
punishments available to the people in
private trust so in private trust what's
available to the people is for trustees
who breach is
litigation
arbitration firing and so on well in the
public trust they added to those those
were the bare minimum because they said
the public trust breach should be more
severe than the private trust so they
added to those impeachments so on and so
forth but they never did away with the
litigation arbitration and so on and
so just like the people the uh just like
the um dcys has to follow due process
when the people are planning to
arbitrate or litigate their trustees
they need to follow due process and one
of the things they do is they provide
notice that's the first step is the
people provide notice to their trust es
alleging that they are acting outside
the trust so on and so forth and we give
the trustees an opportunity to respond
we've sent you all notices here and I
think Sandy responded to one of them but
I don't think we've gotten responses
from the rest of you after that we will
proceed to giving an affidavit just like
due process just like the government has
to provide due process we'll provide you
due process and we'll we'll give you
affidavits testifying to whether or not
you have responded to our awful
notices
now um a unrebutted
affidavits and uncontroverted affidavits
must be accepted as Truth by courts and
I can I'm going to leave you with four
court cases proving that an unre
unrebutted affidavit uncontroverted
affidavit must be accepted as true so
that brings me to the fact that we sent
notice to DCF back in October telling
them to produce evidence that they give
true do process to the people the New
Hampshire 115 style that Leah Kush has
put on the record here so plausible
deniability has been
removed demanding them to produce
evidence that they have given this true
do process to anyone that they have put
on a child endangerment list or uh
terminated parental rights and so on and
so forth we instructed Leah kushman in
that notice to follow up with them if
they if they refuseed to respond to
further investigate the matter she did
that and the
DCF uh attorney basically responded
saying sarily we are within
constitutional due process well I I hope
that you can all see and agree that a
court of law whether it be arbitration
or a conventional Court I don't believe
the judge is going to accept a summary
statement from an attorney as sufficient
and substit evidence to overcome and
controvert the claims made in the
notices now this week several several
people here and and all the further all
the previous testimonies have sent
affidavits into DCF and uh we sent
affidavits into DCF this week following
up on their refusal to provide evidence
so when they fail to rebut or produce
evidence to show you guys that they're
giving the true constitutional due
process not ACLU definition the founding
Generations definition when they fail to
do that then you must take those
uncontroverted affidavits as true and
you must assume that they are not giving
true constitutional due process which is
a trial by jury jury of your peers where
the jury gets to hear the facts and the
law because in a jury trial the jury
only hears the facts and then they're
instructed by the judge to follow the
penalty prescribed in the statute as
Leah pointed out the statute is not the
law of the land because the statute must
hear before it condemns statute gives
penalty inside the statute itself so
that cannot be the law of the land the
the people have to be given a trial by
jury of their peers where the jury will
hear the facts and the law and they get
to determine or nullify the law actually
if they don't think it's a good law
until the people get that and they can
prove it so what you guys have to do
what we're giving you lawful
instructions to do today is we want you
to send notice to the DCF and say
respond to the people give them the last
six months cases they can give them to
you they can redact those personal
information names and addresses that's
sensitive but you have to take a look at
the process they're using and determine
whether they are giving the founding
Generations understanding of true du
process before they ruin someone
reputation by putting them on a child
endangerment list before they take
children before they take money and
payment plan uh parenting plans all
those kind of things anytime they do
those things and they haven't given a
jury a trial by jury moving by rule of
common law no
statute then they're violating the
Constitutional due process of the people
and that is an agency that was created
by the legislature so you have the
authority and the responsibility to put
a check on it to put a stop on it we
want you to tell them if they don't
produce this kind of evidence um then
you want to you want all the children
families reunited uh you have the
authority to give Financial reparations
that's also in the historical tradition
and we can prove it that you can give
Financial reparations to the families
that were harmed um we want you to take
PE people name off of a child
endangerment list all these people who
have been railroaded by this this entire
system that does not give due process
right from the start you guys are the
ones that are on the hook the
responsibility to fix it because you
created that agency you have authority
over that agency it's your
responsibility and your plausible
deniability is gone because we put it
all out
here that's my testimony thank you very
testimony Robert take
cray take her a t a tangue it was hard
didn't okay real quick I was just sorry
I was just informed I should have taken
questions if there any questions um I
don't see any questions from the
you okay uh my name is Robert tangue uh
I'm the author of incentives in
environment and also New Hampshire
Oliver Twist uh I have not seen my
children in over a year there are
conflicting
orders uh in the family
courts that are ordering me and
compelling me sorry yes you could move
the microphone and for everybody else
that talks if you could speak into the
microphone that way everybody can hear
thank thank you Greg um so there's
conflicting orders there's orders
telling me uh with a fictitious domestic
violence petition which I can get into
that but there's orders telling me that
I can't see my kids compelling me to
talk to the protected party and then
there's
orders which are
lawful even though 173b protective
orders are unconstitutional that says
that the police must arrest me if I
communicate and they've help the court
has held me into contempt um I'm going
to start out with I was listening to the
committee and I appreciate all your time
um it's not your fault that this has
happened you have a decision what to do
today based on this information
including what the gentleman just said
which I agree in part a lot with and I
have uh things to back that up but what
you guys were talking about um you
talking about the courts so rule 38 of
the Supreme Court is uh judicial conduct
you're going to want to look at that
because a judge has a duty to report
judici uh judicial misconduct and also
professional misconduct which is for
lawyers and lawyers have a duty to
report judges and also the 0311 colon 6
where it under Pains of penalty of
perjury to get their license they swear
before The Supreme Court that they will
correct anything that is
incorrect and uh will not take any case
for lucer which is money and and so on
when someone has a lawyer they become a
ward of the court that means they're
incapable of uh representing themselves
and then the court uh laer is an officer
of the court so the the unknown secret
is that judges don't report on judges
and or or lawyers and lawyers don't
report on judges and that's what we have
our entire system respectfully in the
state of New Hampshire is corrupt all
the way up to the Supreme Court um and
that's where we're getting to the point
of impeachment and specific facts on
Friday I have a uh order which has from
the Supreme Court they're hiding the
fraud uh that's taking place in court
um judges have no discretion when it
law uh you guys have the right to
impeach the house has the right to
impeach and uh the duty to I would
assert and then it goes the Senate um
when they're not acting within the
Constitution the governor knows about
this Governor shonu um and his entire
administration every single Supreme
Court Justice if I'm not mistaken has
been appointed by Governor including
Gordon McDonald which was sorry can we
not get into names please we're event
say the current one uh we're talking
about the policies not the people so if
you can say the current one and just
speak to it that way
well the only I'm coming here cuz I'm in
fear I have no other recourse what do
you do when the Supreme Court hides
fraud knowing fraud and writes
bogus orders that violate the federal
rules of civil
procedure they've stricken my briefs so
I've given I think it's Federal rule of
civil procedure on striking uh on uh
amended appeals by a matter of court
course uh it you have 21 days for
responsive pleading amended it's a
matter of course meaning you're allowed
to do that they're hiding it and because
we don't want to say names because you
got a Supreme Court Justice husband
who's just got put on paid leave last
week was in the
news on
Wednesday and that goes by the name of
Marone I'm sorry but we're going to have
to say that
and she's a member of the me uh women's
Bar
Association and I have a contract I want
you to write this down um this is the
stop 2023 stop violence against women
act formula
grant there's a contract
number uh which I can pull up but
basically uh they only protect
women the service traing Law Enforcement
Officers judges Court personnel and
prosecutors to more effectively identify
respond to violent crimes against women
including the crimes of sexual assault
developing training blah blah blah blah
blah point of order Madam chairman yeah
point w State your point of order thank
you thank you for suspending for a
minute um we are hearing specifically
DCF matters so I'm wondering if we are
not
straying a fair ways away from dcyf
matters and I'm hoping that um if there
if DCF is involved in in these cases
which I'm I'm not clear about you will
explain to us how DCF is involved rather
than uh what sounds like a broader
issues that you have with the court
system so thank you um thank you for
that point of order I agree it's it's
hard to understand how to make that
actionable since our charge is DCF if
you could get to the relationship with
DCF that would help us to be able to
potentially do something to help you
certainly so I reported this to dcyf
also on December
uh
14th
2022 the conquer uh the Manchester
police have a police report they
self-reported to
dcyf um there's a lot of collusion
that's going on with the the Manchester
police the Manchester police officer was
just arrested for violating this is
again last week uh for
violating um he has six counts of
violence uh and one count of op uh
hiding a crime he was arrested by the
state TR Troopers he self turned himself
in so what happens is the the women's
Bar Association Jerry Manders the family
courts they specifically on their on
their page it says that they are uh for
families and women women and families
gain equity in women and families and
women and children specifically and then
they also said that they talk to judges
government officials including dcy so we
have a Prejudice and so when when you
see what happens you you'll hear mostly
men or but when it's women it's because
they don't act like they're supposed to
act which is submissive they fight for
their rights women aren't supposed to
that's the bias that's going on in our
courtrooms so again everything is done
by court so so so some of the I just
want to let you guys know because I
wrote some notes when you're speaking
and I really appreciate I think they
we're trying to figure this out I even R
Greg I appreciate we have some
different but I think that you really
care I think we all really care so the
police when you report this to the
police they're mandatory
reporter DCF should be working with the
police to make an arrest
arrest arrest of the crime probable
cause is all that you need sometimes a
police officer could call and say say
hey I have some questions we heard this
concern it needs to start with the
police and then work with DCF because
the entire purpose of the criminal
system is for refer reform and that's by
Statute reform we're trying to fix this
we are humans now obviously when it gets
to the point of someone being Beat to
Death Or severely
abused that's a big deal but if someone
loses their temper and an accident
happens we want to nip that in the bud
and give them the resources that they
need no drugs were involved in my case
and that's where it really comes down to
the people who have the most money you
will never see a kid getting taken away
from a rich family it is only the poor
since the beginning of time and there's
historical uh backups for that and uh
where they used to uh go in in the 1600s
and I have this in a memorandum of law
in the 1600s they used to go and um to
the people's houses and they would take
the children away if they felt the
father was
not working the child enough because
children used to work very young on the
farms and
such so I think I the problem you're
saying that you're having all these
positions we're getting all these
positions it's like calling customer
service in India they are powerless
positions we need more directors and
subdirector it's the same corporate
mentality that we have um you call
someone up they can't do anything about
it I heard a little bell yeah so I would
like you guys to ask me some questions
because I'm a wealth of knowledge uh but
did the judges are lying physically and
mathematically impossible findings of
fact and then they're burying them
physically and mathematically imposs
findings of fact and violation of law
the last thing I got from my children at
after I
complained was some stuff so and if you
could just wrap it up um so and one of
these things I I'm sure that's beautiful
art we'll take a look at it afterwards
but just showing all of that's not
really down this is what my son sent to
me the mother the only thing the mother
sent to me I was a stay-at-home dad do
you see that do you guys see that you
see that am I an African-American
family okay now my kids never had
counseling
before who's see how the mother has both
the
children and fathers over
here this is what they really want if
you break up a family for no reason it
is abuse on the family it is a tort it
is a damage to a family constitutionally
the contract that the Covenant the
marriage there isn't no fault so what
you have what you have isor you you
don't have lawyers so thank you I think
we've gone pretty far from the DCF on it
it's hard because this is something that
is so personal that's why we try and
give some leeway okay I'll put it I'll
put it right to DCF okay human
trafficking 633 so um with that you've
actually you've had your 10 minutes of
testifying I have a feeling that you
probably will be back with our next one
again I don't want to come back I'm here
right now and I have a right to respond
to you guys I just want to put it to to
help you sorry if you do have a right to
respond we'll see if we have any other
questions you would ask for 10 minutes
you've gone for 12 minutes um this is
one where we have other people that are
leaving we still have two other people
to speak and we have 10 minutes left
before the top of the hour I want to
make sure that going beyond your time
doesn't harm the ability of others to
speak so I don't know if there's any
questions here from members of the
committee um I don't see questions from
members of the committee you guys don't
ask any questions of anybody who
actually knows it so 633 col 7 is human
trafficking by abuse of the legal
process and so that is abusing my
children that's what I reported to dcyf
and the police and the Attorney General
John formela they're not doing what
they're supposed to do your committee
needs to take note and follow the law
the judges aren't following the law
thank you so much thank you for your
testimony Eric
I apologize it's my first time up here
doing this and uh as a person uh that's
been battling this for 12 years so the
first part if you can get a little
closer to the microphone give us your
name um I'll set it for the 10 minutes
but I'll sort of put my hands up if you
feel like you're you're you're
struggling at all so if you want to call
it short you can I appreciate it U my
name is Eric Blair I live out of um
Grafton County Leon New Hampshire um
I've been battling with um off and on
with child protective services and the
weaponization they
apologize sorry I'm I'm guilty of it now
if you can move the microphone straight
in front of you so it's facing you
straight on perfect this a little better
much better much better sorry I'm not
usually a public speaker so I
apologize um St again my name is Eric
Blair I'm from grafting County Lebanon
New Hampshire um I have dealt with
Sullivan County's uh dcyf for the past
at least nine years I think since 2015
off and on um with false allegations
from my my ex um my daughter's been in
multiple friends of
interviews um and every time continually
she says you know Daddy's done nothing
wrong but still this agency goes above
and beyond its Call of Duty to break the
rules um and again has been used in
court as weaponization by my ex um
several rights has been violated and I
haven't seen her
since beginning of the school year last
year when I was invited to by her
teacher to uh first day at school and it
the smile on her face was priceless you
know you know she's followed her father
in her
footsteps um the sad part is is there is
no accountability I know we talked about
a little bit earlier listening to you
guys about committee hearings multiple
ones before things happen never happened
um I had maybe one Committee hearing
where multiple people came and testified
on my behalf for being a great father um
I've had my child come to church with me
um and the first thing the pastor
noticed was
was she used me as her defense Shield
because she's never met him before that
doesn't sound like a a person that
abuses his child um it's been very tough
on myself and I'm here as there is an
affidavit there I turned in um to DCF um
in reference to this because I don't
want other parents to go through this
you know having one parent be able to go
to DCF and it's weaponized against the
other parent whether it's female or male
is just not right um do I understand
their short staffed could that be an
issue possibly but there's got to be a
point where people's rights are
upheld you know you yours rights for a
reason the Constitution's put in for a
reason you can't C go around those
corners and now my daughter's paying the
price I am seeing some medical files
because I still have access to her
visits and some of the stuff that's
going on because of the involvement of
DCF she's not doing well and somewhere
along the lines we have to hold the line
because I'm a very big advocate of if
you're abusing your child you shouldn't
have
them I I'm I'm here because I'm on the
other side of that I've had to go to the
state of Maine and have the governor's
office re get um Sullivan County
involved because there was a wanted
fugitive in the house with my child I've
had to to call DCF because she was in
another situation a couple years later
in a house with sex Traffic Offenders
that were being investigated DCF did
nothing they held a hearing with the
court an hour before my hearing without
me being in there to hear what was going
on after a three-month investigation
where my ex was instructed to have her
and my child and um therapy which I
demanded I'm in it too for all the stuff
that I've had to deal with with the
system um three months after that
issuing she took my child out of again
for I think it was the third time out of
therapy because the truth was starting
to come out dcyf sat and didn't stop her
nor did the
court this has to change for the
children's sake they're our future she's
my
legacy and to not have her here because
of a broken system and somewhat corrupt
in certain areas things need to change
you know as a person of the state you
know I am a civil servant I work for the
government so it's my job I took an oath
to protect and defend the Constitution
foreign domestic so I'm here to try to
fight for other parents that can't be
here to that are afraid to come up in
front of you and speak I am a little bit
today as myself so I
apologize it's been a really rough road
and I'm hoping this committee can make
changes and fix it maybe do some patches
it was fixed in the first place we
shouldn't have it done patches now this
is just my opinion on
this and if there's any questions feel
free to ask I'll sit here and
answer um thank you I want to say that
you did a phenomenal job speaking with
us uh representative long you have a
question thank you madam thank thank you
for your uh testimony yes sir uh do you
visit your daughter now I have not had
any visitations with my child my ex has
changed her phone numbers um multiple
occasions she doesn't reach out to help
me set up any
visits um so it's been very hard
constitutional rights have been violated
to make sure I haven't been able to have
visits I'm a lawful Second Amendment
carrier and was instructed by a judge
that in order for visitations my firearm
could not go out with me in public which
is concealed 90% of the time my child's
nowhere around it not near to be allowed
near it um they basically said if she
was allowed to come for visits they have
to be has to be put up so at any moment
if someone were to break into my house
and I use my firearm to defend me and my
child I would be B basically breaking a
court law so at this point I have not
had any visitations of my child due to
this on top of the fact that again the
ex has not allowed me to have
any way of communication with
her um and as you know I am a postal
worker so the background checks are
serious so I mean I have not had any
violations in no
record but this judge still had the
weaponization of dcyf to come up with
this
rule follow yes follow up so so if you
complied with what they're requesting
you uh with due to your second amendment
would you be able to see your daughter
as as long as I followed that court
order to the tea I wouldn't be able to
carry it with me outside to protect her
if we went on any trips outside of the
state or anything and as long as it's up
and out locked away when she's here so
like I said any situation that um could
violate the protection of her or myself
I would would be breaking the court law
to protect her and how long has it been
it um my own property at my house two
years last was in school first day of
school last
year thank you thank you thank you um so
with us with you not being able to
possess your firearm is that only when
you're with her or at any time in order
to have that visitation in order to have
that visitation at any time at any time
so you could can't have it with you at
any other time or just during the
schedule of visitation no the Bas
sorry I cannot have it when she is in my
presence which is still an infringment
but I just wanted to get a clarification
if that was all time no anywhere I go
it's usually on my side I'm not afraid
to protect anyone that needs it at any
given time but unfortunately the judge
felt well you know since the X made up
lies that this is what we're going to do
um sorry do you mind if I ask if there
were any findings within your case or
actually I don't even know enough
questions to ask so I'm not going to ask
because I'm just going to be digging
myself in a hole and I'm probably
getting overly personal at question
there were every time that my ex put in
for a finding they were all unfounded
okay and in fact anyone that was on my
side actually there was more witnesses
on my side to backup that they weren't
true representative
Weber thank you for that so so as a
followup you've never had a DCF case
that's unfounded is that correct correct
I mean I mean you've never had I didn't
ask that correctly Sor you've never no
it's my fault I'm not being clear um
you've never had a founded dcyf case so
all of the orders that you're talking
about are coming through your divorce
case is that correct um DCF has shown up
in the court cases multiple times in one
incident um there was a exp parte order
put because my daughter was bleeding in
her private area and my ex accused me of
it brought dcyf invol
it was founded that actually my daughter
fell and hurt herself that caused it but
instead they used the court system to
weaponize it against me I see so so your
complaint is that DCF has become
involved in the other case true ma'am
and and am I correct and also
understanding that there are times when
you have wanted DCF to be involved for
the safety of your daughter and you feel
feel that they have not intervened
correctly is that correct in a few
occasions yes okay great thank you very
much for that clarification that's very
you thank you for sharing that I wish I
could formulate the questions that I
want to ask for more information but I'm
sorry about um just the way that this is
going I think my numbers on the
affidavit or my address if you want to
you can reach out I would feel free to
answer anything thank you I greatly
appreciate that thank you for hearing me
thank you and with that I'll call
Representative
kushman thank you madam chair and
members of the committee it's good to
see you all so I'm going to try and I
put five minutes I could speak really
really fast and hope that you all can
keep up or I can try to um kind of go at
a little slower Pace um I I want to
bring together pretty much everything
that's been discussed here to make it
more clear how this all
works
so first we have the issues within DCF
right um they do their administrative
tribunals where they do not provide
notice to
appear they hold their little tribunal
privately so they've
investigated and they're paid to to
investigate then they're paid to hold
the
tribunal then they're also paid to make
they okay um
and the the person can never appear to
provide evidence against themselves
until appeal you get a letter in the
mail saying you John Smith have been
found guilty in our hearing of abuse and
or
neglect and you have the opportunity to
appeal and that's the first time that
you can go there and present evidence um
of your
innocence now this usually follows a
interview with a DCF
worker um but that is not due process at
all and once you're on once they so you
don't get that notice the the tribunal
is not impartial
um because basically DCF is in their own
case against you and then they're making
the finding in the case against you it's
like if your judge came and investigated
the crime you were committed committing
and then you know dealt your punishment
before you ever got to court um so
there's the issues there
then you're put on a list um a a
nationwide list so that's harming your
liberty interest right right there your
reputation all of that which under
common law case precedent it's all been
found to be harm right so then go to
Family Court if they find have a finding
of guilt they may they may close the
case DCF may say you abused your child
but we're going to close the case
there's a problem for children
right um or they may bring an affidavit
to petition the court to start that
process um in family
court and correct uh someone had
mentioned that it's often hearsay so
they'll write in the affidavit uh the
neighbor reported this that and the
other thing and that's not a true
affidavit so they'll get you in there
um and so the issues in the court are
also there's no
impartiality so so first of all to have
Equity your accuser needs to have a
consequence for falsely accusing you
knowingly so where we have a situation
where a mandated reporter has no
consequence for making an accusation
against you and they um and then it can
be weaponized by um you know one or the
other spouse in a
divorce and there is no consequence so
like in criminal uh filings like if
someone you file a police report or an
affidavit to a court about a police
you're subject to perjury and you're
subject to the crime of filing false
police report that's that's where you
get equity and criminal proceedings
that's missing from the
DCF
issue
um so then you get into the court and
everyone in the court from DCF to the
guardian Ed lims and not all of them but
some of them um any psychiatrists
psychologists Physicians that are
ordered to provide services to the
parent or the
child um the referees or magistrates
because they're not judges in there by
by the payment structure that that comes
from the federal government that pays
them they are not acting judges in
Family Court they are magistrates
they're not Court officers that's why
there's no
perjury and so all of those people are
getting paid by the same Federal
programs
so there's no impartiality the court is
incentivized to bring in as many cases
as they can and to prolong them and drag
them out as long as they can and issue
orders and a lot of them know their
friends in the court they're friends
with the visitation center owners they
have their favorite
G's it is a very perverse system of
justice this is limited in a criminal
court because you don't have this
opportunity for federal Contracting to
chase after federal
funds so up until the 1970s child abuse
and neglect cases were dealt with in
Criminal Court and it wasn't until I
think the late 80s and early 90s that
dcyf came into the picture we've got all
these hands in the pot it is turning
Justice on its
head and there was some discussion about
uh we need more middle management I
think it's it's it's not the middle
management that we need middle
management are the ones who know about
the funding incentives and I've talked
to dcyf case workers who are
whistleblowers who say it's not the head
who comes in and tries to fix things and
it's not the people on the ground for
the most part who are carrying out the
day-to-day um work case work but the
middle management that is looking for
the funding so I believe that the
solution is to
put they the family court was created to
like mix all of these civil criminal and
Equity
cases and it it doesn't work that way
because there's a different way to
handle all of those under common law and
they came in and said forget what the
the case the jurist Prudence system um
has declared to be right over you know
hundreds and hundreds of years of you
know fi case findings and court rulings
plus the principles of of law we're
going to write it in statute and mix
them all together and this is how the
Court's going to move so it has it's
just really not the way that it's
supposed to work and it's so complicated
when really law is supposed to be very
simple and it is if you parse all of
those pieces out separately so if a
divorce
a um if you're having a divorce that
would be an equity because you're
dividing up property that's and they got
rid of equity courts
a couple decades ago but that would be
straight Equity if there's a component
of domestic violence then one of the
divorce a goes and files a police report
or an affidavit to the court to confer
jurisdiction and then abuse and neglect
is also criminal then if they have civil
claims they can pursue that in Civil
Court combining all of these things
under these statutes where Federal
funding is what being chased has just
completely clouded Justice in the
ability to give it
now if we funded this since the
1997 child abuse cases have increased
over
800%
Nationwide I do not believe that it is
because parents are abusing their kids
more because we've actually moved to a
point in society where abuse is very
highly frowned upon and shamed even
corporal punishment
is I think that these incentives have
created the this kind of case
handling and and I do believe there is
some
corruption I think that there are some
some impeachments that need to follow
some real serious investigations I think
that there are subpoenas that need to be
sought after and potentially even
warrants the house has that ability also
um I won't talk about
names and I know that's ringing I just
want to cut touch on
a okay okay um the problem with the New
Hampshire courts in
particular in in the 70s late '70s there
was a constitutional convention and
article 72a and 73a were added um passed
by the people but the last couple of
words of article 73a concerning that the
the um Supreme Court would make the
rules of the Court they were not
included on the ballot that went out to
the people and those words are and they
shall have the effect of law or the
force of law so that's something to
investigate also that this this phrase
is not actually in our
Constitution and common law is supposed
to in Rules of Evidence are never
supposed to be waved um um and and they
use that and they use discretion to
um to kind of do whatever they want it's
a it's kind of lawlessness in the court
so
that's thank you for coming with that
information and thank you for remaining
engaged on this topic
um I'll take any questions if anyone has
one
so I don't see any questions so thank
you very much okay thank you thank you
um and with this I will close our um I
will close the meeting we will be
noticing again for a meeting next week
um same time I will try and get the
office of the child advocate or DCF in
um we may end up uh as we try and bring
them in figuring out exactly how much
time to have on work sessions versus um
hearing from the public just to make
sure we're managing our time but I think
we had a great discussion during that
first hour so with that thank you very
um so I think we won't uh we won't be
meeting next week um we will be waiting
meeting a week after that I'd like to
know your availability the Mondays until
um we move into summer so we know which
ones and so we can get people on our
dance card to come and speak with us so